anthony st légier nous avons besoin nous
a rejoints bonsoir en france et sur les
réseaux sociaux des comptes opposé à
vladimir poutine assure que le président
russe met en scène ses déplacements
effectivement à vladimir poutine qui
emploieraient des figurants pour jouer
les citoyens lambda et même selon
certains il serait tellement paranoïaque
il aurait tellement peur pour sa vie
surtout dans le contexte actuel que ce
sont ses gardes du corps qui jouerait
les figurants c'est la thèse défendue
par cette publication vous le voyez qui
frôle les 8 me like un tout de même et
qui est sûre la donc ce sont à ces
gardes du corps qui joue tantôt les
soldats blessés dans un hôpital comme ce
serait le cas dans cette photo est
tantôt elle les ouvriers d'une usine
alors l'idéal est soutenu aussi par cet
internaute dont la publication cumul
quand même les plus de 40000 like et qui
s'amuse donc de cette étrange
coïncidence des tweets de ce type 1
pullulent depuis le 26 mai le lendemain
de du déplacement de vladimir poutine à
l'hôpital militaire à moscou première
visite en trois mois de guerre à des
soldats russes décès alors si la
ressemblance est frappante l'homme de
l'hôpital n'est pas celui de lusine non
c'est le résultat d'une enquête d'arthur
bahamas des observateurs de france 24 va
revoir tout même les deux images en
question donc les deux hommes encadrés
ici en rose d'où vient d'abord l'image
de l'hôpital et bien précisément de
cette visite du 25 mai dont je vous
parlais il s'agit bien d'un soldat
blessé on retrouve d'ailleurs est cette
image dans cette vidéo notamment publié
le jour même par le média britannique
the sun et qui nous offre regarder un
autre un autre angle de vue celui qu'on
a vu assez subrepticement que l'on voit
ici l'homme à gauche donc et c'est cet
autre angle de vue qui va nous permettre
de noter des différences visuelles sinon
mais à côté à l'autre photo par exemple
c'est tout bête mais l'implantation des
cheveux ici et qui n'est absolument pas
la même que ici ou encore la forme des
sourcils plutôt rectangulaire
dirons-nous à gauche est plutôt
arrondies à droite notamment pour les
différences visuelles donc voilà pour la
première image pour ce qui est de la
deuxième image à présent on la retrouve
ici sur le site
le kremlin on est le 9 novembre 2017 et
à cette époque vladimir poutine est en
visite dans l'usiné à 4 4 one is in de
compresseur industriel à tcheliabinsk s
est ici bien à l'est de moscou lé point
rouge sur la carte et vladimir poutine
il rencontre les ouvriers de cette usine
dont haras ville d'aoste offs et le nom
de l'homme en question et que l'on
retrouve d'ailleurs trois ans après dans
une vidéo le 17 mars 2020 une vidéo
publiée sur le site de l'usiné et il y
est présenté comme responsable de la
chaîne d'assemblage alors deuxième
exemple d'un fox similaire à la première
il est question de fou pêcheurs cette
fois effectivement des pêcheurs qui
seraient en réalité des agents
gouvernementaux c'est ce qu'affirment
plusieurs publications notamment sur
twitter en prenant ces deux photos donc
à gauche vladimir poutine en présence de
pêcheurs sur un bateau et à droite
vladimir poutine lors d'une messe et
vous voyez d'ailleurs que les
internautes se sont amusés déjà à faire
le jeu des cinq différence qu'en est il
réellement là encore en noir turbin ce
qui lui revient on retrouve la photo de
gauche a d'abord sur le site du kremlin
toujours vous la reconnaissez ici on est
le 10 septembre 2016 dans la région de
novgorod c'est ici plutôt au nord ouest
cette fois de moscou quant à la deuxième
photo regardez on la retrouve elle aussi
sur le site du kremlin ici on est le 7
janvier 2010 est toujours dans la région
de hand of god et ce n'est pas pour rien
donc il s'agit donc contrairement aux
premiers exemples des mêmes personnes et
pour cause je vous le disais puisque là
on est dans une messe de noël à un efron
mais regardez bien lorsque l'on regarde
un petit peu plus la description
regarder la précision faite par le
kremlin qui précise bien que pendant
cette messe et plus particulièrement
cette visite est bien le président russe
vladimir poutine a bien rencontré elle
les pêcheurs qu'ils avaient déjà
rencontrés en 2007 cqfd donc mais parce
qu'il ya un mais notons toutefois que la
visite tu as été savamment orchestrée
sur plan de la communication aux
politiques on peut faire confiance à
vladimir poutine là dessus puisque cette
dame blonde que le voit n'est une
farouche pas farouche pas tant que ça si
on le regarde la photo mais militants
pro poutine qui plus est entrepreneuse
dans l'industrie de la pêche qui est
devenue célèbre justement pour ce baiser
reçu de vladimir poutine le sel fille
était devenue virale à l'époque merci
beaucoup anthony st léger pour ses
explications on se quitte quelques
instants on se retrouve tout de suite
pour un nouveau journal dans ce paris
direct vous restez avec nous